one thing I've learned about leadership
over the years is that 90% plus of the
decisions that leaders make they make
behind closed doors when the cameras
aren't there and what's guiding them in
those moments are their values at some
point we came to think that the values
of our leaders don't matter that it's
just their policy positions that matter
but that couldn't be further from the
truth I think this moment in particular
is one where values matter so we as
individual citizens have the power to
shift culture and to choose a core set
of values centered around
kindness and generosity and service and
friendship centered fundamentally around
love and we can do that by the choices
we make in our homes in our communities
at The Ballot Box cuz that's how we
change society